When thinking about
creating a community,
I want you to think about why someone
would want to join your community.
One of the reasons people join
communities is because they enjoy it.
If people are internally motivated,
you'll see more long term,
sustainable relationships made.
There's also the goal of creating
a community that has a good balance
between people enjoying or
having fun in your community, but
also getting use out of it.
Let's hear from Amir and
Telly on other tips on how to
engage with your community.
>> So, a community is a group of people,
who share the same mission or
passion and have the same goal,
want to achieve the same goal.
A community could be anything from,
a physical community.
People come and meet and talk about
something all the way to an online
community, and
we see a lot of these happening lately.
So, first of all you need to understand
what is the need, what is the mission?
A community is a part,
is a group of the mission, so
if you have a mission that needs
a community, that needs the scale.
Then that's a good hint,
that you need a community.
It's also really, a way for
you to achieve something.
So think about,
what do I want to achieve?
And if I can use other people's passion,
to get what I want to achieve.
Just know that it needs to
be a joint passion, right?
You need to work with them
towards a joined goal.
So, first of all,
you need to be very engaged with them.
They're volunteers.
They're passionate about what your
trying to solve, but you always need to
engage, be transparent, tell them
we found this bug, we're fixing it.
Make them feel that they
are part of the process.
In order to build a value for
your community,
you need to come up with three things,
which I think are very important for
every member of the community.
Growth, fun, and belonging.
So, if you analyze what
are the aspects of your community that
contribute to the members growth,
fun, and belonging.
These are the three things that will
create the value for your members and
maintain them.
Not every start up needs
an online community.
Many startups are just about
a user interaction, right?
Mint is an amazing app, but
it doesn't need a community.
It has interaction,
which is simple and intuitive, and
does not require community.
There are other startups,
lately that really rely on
a community to be successful.
Sometimes they rely on two
communities to be successful, and
it's really important, and
it provides you with a scale,
that you don't have if you
don't have this community.
So a lot of the startups need social
interaction, a lot of the market places.
These are types of start ups
that really need a community.
When you want to seed interaction,
when you have interaction imbedded into
the app that requires a lot of people.
So good examples for companies
that need community are Uber for
example, a community of drivers.
A Messenger would be a good example.
Google, of course we have a big
community of world developer community.
A place where you have a marketplace
would be a good example.
So a good way to get people to join
a community is have a good goal.
If the goal would be I
want to make money for
myself, that's probably not a goal where
you can get a lot of people to join you.
Right?
But getting people educated all
over the world is an amazing goal.
And you can really get people inspired.
And very engaged with this type of goal.
A community of one person or
two people is probably boring, and
it's not really a community.
You need to have critical mass
in order to start a community.
There's a process called seeding,
where you have a call to action, or
you hack into other communities
to seed your own community.
So think of it.
There's many ways to create to
do the seeding of the community.
One of the things would be to go to
another community, and say hey guys,
we're opening a new community,
why don't you join us?
Another way is to go through,
social channels.
And talk about your passion,
about the mission and
get people excited about them.
I've seen startups that just have a
coffee, and talked about certain topic.
Before they even started a community,
they just say hey guys if
your interested in this topic,
come to mission.
A street in San Francisco.
Have some coffee with us and
we'll talk about this.
Once you get people excited and engaged,
you can create a online community or
an offline community out of that.
The way to grow a community
from a small community or
a big community, is to think about
the value for the members, right?
How can, creating a bigger community
will add more value to the members?
Some people call it the K factor,
the virality.
You need to think about what
incentives are there, for
people inside the community to
add more people to the community.
Right?
What is the incentive, what's in it for
them, to grow the community.
Some communities don't
feel like growing, right?
Some communities say hey I want to keep
my community size small because I know
everybody here.
And that could be amazing, right?
A lot of our,
Google developer communities,
are small because of that, right?
They don't want ten thousand
people in which they don't know.
But if you want to grow and
if you want to scale, you'll need to
build incentives, to get people
excited about growing the community.
Okay, I think the key things with
running a good community is treating
your community well.
Being communicative transparent, having
a joint mission that is passionate for
you, and passionate for the community.
Keep fostering a community.
Make sure that you maintain the
community, that people don't drop off.
A big mistakes that I see startups do,
is they create a community but
they don't invest in the community.
So I think investing in
the community is very important.
Take the fun very seriously.
Take the growth very seriously.
Take the belonging very seriously.
And always think of how
do I invest in these, and
how do I maintain my community.
A community is something
very precious and
if you don't invest in it, it will die.
And getting in the community
the second time,
is like getting someone to fall
in love with you the second time.
It’s really hard.
So, investment and continue and
maintain your community.
So, when I joined develop
relations on Google,
I was tasked to create a Google
developer communities.
These are communities of developers
that meets on a monthly or
quarterly basis to
talk about technology.
So the first thing I did was,
to source community leaders.
So I came, and I tried to find good
speakers, where people are passionate
about communities and just say,
hey, I'm starting this community.
The mission is to empower people through
technology, you want to join me?
Most of them said no.
Some of them said yes.
Those are those who wanted to
actually work with me, and
to create this community.
Join me, and we just had coffee, and
we talked about how do
we create the community?
So they started creating
their own community, but
the key was to maintain them, right?
To keep them passionate.
So every month I just went to the best
restaurant I could find in the area,
gathered them together and
just talked about cool stuff.
So I created a meta community,
of my community leaders.
They felt that they're empowered.
They felt that they're amongst people
that are very passionate about
these things, and
they feel that they belong.
So I actually managed to get
them excited about building
communities for me.
>> Yeah, so community management.
I think, first and foremost it's about,
really understanding your users, and
what they need, and how to connect them
in ways that are meaningful to them.
So for us,
a lot of it was understanding that we
need the moderator in every community.
So, we went and did that.
Or understanding that we needed
very specific guidelines,
because this is a community, it's about
sharing and people get confused about
what is sharing, what isn't sharing,
what kind of things can you share?
And we kind of learned that
from our community and
from our users as they
were doing these things.
Sometimes we thought, oh, this is okay,
but then we got [INAUDIBLE] from
the community saying,
that actually offended me.
So you kind of learn it over time,
and you define the guidelines.
And we realize that it's very necessary
to have community guidelines,
that kind of explaining exactly why and.
Once you have those, people will
respect that and abide by that.
So if they do something that's kind of
wrong and you kind of tell him,
oh it's on the guidelines, so they're
okay, and they're not offended by it.
The role of a moderator is just
making sure that everybody sticks by
the guidelines, so if they try to
pull something that's irrelevant, or
not family friendly,
or not sharing related.
They will just, you know, moderate that
content out, and explain to the user
that, because it's a lot of times
it's not intentional, right?
The user was just genuinely
thinking that they could
use this platform for this.
So they just want to
see this explanation,
and be referred to the guidelines.